MOST MISERABLE ON EARTH.
HE WAS FORCED TO  A -- APOLOGIZE
FOR EVERYTHING HE’S GOOD AT.
WHY?
WE GO TO DAVE PORTNOY.
SHE WAS WATCHING LAST NIGHT’S
DEBATE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
DAVE, YOU ARE A STUDENT OF HUMAN
NATURE.
YOU WATCH WHAT HAPPENED WITH
BLOOMBERG.
YOU’RE NOT A BLOOMBERG HATER OR
ANYTHING.
BUT TELL ME YOUR REACTION TO IT.
>> YEAH, NO, I DIDN’T HAVE ANY
OPINION ABOUT BLOOMBERG.
I WAS WATCHING COLLEGE
BASKETBALL.
IT WAS A THREE OVERTIME GAME.
I FLIPPED TO THE DEBATE RIGHT
WHEN BLOOMBERG WAS GETTING
CRUCIFIED.
THE ONLY THING I KNOW IS WHEN HE
TRIED TO GET RID OF BIG COKES.
THIS WAS LIKE WATCHING "GAME OF
THRONES."
SOMEBODY GETTING EXECUTED IN
FRONT OF YOUR EYES.
IF EVERY DEBATE WAS LIKE THAT, I
WOULD TUNE IN.
THAT WAS BETTER THAN ANYTHING
LIKE YOU SEE ON HBO OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
FOR A BILLIONAIRE, SOMEBODY YOU
WOULD THINK IS SMART, HE LOOKED
TOTALLY CAUGHT OFF GUARD BY
EVERYTHING THEY WERE SAYING
ABOUT HIM.
LIKE SOME PEOPLE DON’T LIKE ME.
NOT MANY.
SOME.
BUT I KNOW IF I’M IN A DEBATE
WITH SOMEBODY THAT DOESN’T LIKE
ME, I CAN PRETTY MUCH READ WHAT
THEY’RE GOING TO DO, THE
GREATEST HITS.
HE LOOKED TOTALLY CONFUSED.
LIKE WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
I DIDN’T KNOW PEOPLE WOULD BRING
THIS UP.
IT WAS STUNNING AND FUN TO
WATCH.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU’RE
BLOOMBERG, HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND?
HOW SHOULD HE HAVE RESPONDED?
>> ONCE HE HESITATED AND ONCE HE
PANICKED AND ONCE HE WAS GOING
DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE, IF I WERE
HIM, I WOULD HAVE WALKED OFF.
THE HELL WITH IT.
I HAVE BILLIONS.
I DON’T NEED THIS IN MY LIFE.
THERE’S NO COMING BACK.
SOMEBODY LIKE ME THAT IS NEUTRAL
ON HIM THINKS HE’S A VILLAGE
IDIOT.
THERE’S NO WAY TO RESPOND.
THE REST OF THE DEBATE HE WAS
OKAY.
BUT ONCE YOU GET ABSENTLY
SAVAGED LIKE THAT AND YOU HAVE
NO COMEBACK AND THEY’RE DANCING
AROUND PUNCHING YOU LIKE A
PIÑATA, IT’S DONE.
IT’S GAME OVER.
THERE’S NOTHING THAT YOU CAN
BUY, NO AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CAN
COME BACK FROM THAT.
HE SHOULD HAVE SAID, I MADE A
MISTAKE.
I’M OUT OF HERE.
AND WHOEVER IS HIS ADVISERS ARE,
I MEAN, THEY SHOULD BE BROUGHT
OUT.
HOW DO YOU NOT TELL HIM HE’S
GOING TO GET THOSE QUESTIONS?
IT’S OBVIOUS.
IT WAS NUTS.
>> Tucker: SO BLOOMBERG IS NOT
MARRIED.
HE HAS A LONG-TIME GIRLFRIEND
THAT HE’S LIVED WITH FOR TEN
YEARS.
HE’S GOING HOME TO HER.
WHAT DOES SHE SAME TO HIM, DO
YOU THINK?
>> SHE’S PROBABLY GOT A GOOD
GIG.
YOU KNOW, GAZILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IT WASN’T THAT BAD.
WHAT ELSE CAN YOU SAY?
IF HE HAS ANY BRAINS HE KNOWS
IT’S BAD.
HE HAD ME SO CONFUSED.
I’M VERY PRO MONEY.
I LIKE MAKING MONEY.
I WANT A GAZILLION DOLLARS.
I WANT THE MONEY HE HAS.
MAYBE HE THINKS YOU’RE NOT SO
SMART.
HOW CAN THIS IDIOT BE UP HERE?
HE HAD ME IN A MIND TRAP.
IF YOU’RE THE GIRLFRIEND, YOU
PLAY ALONG.
MAKE HIM A GRILL CHEESE, PUT
SOME POTATO CHIPS IN THE MIDDLE,
TAP HIM ON THE BACK AND SAY IT
WASN’T THAT BAD.
WHAT ELSE CAN YOU DO?
>> Tucker: SO EVEN MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG CAN GET RICH.
I THINK YOU JUST EXPOSED THE
CENTRAL PROBLEM OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY, WHICH IS IT’S NOT THAT
HARD TO BILLION A ZILLIONAIRE.
>> IF I WAS BERNIE SANDERS, THIS
IS MY CAMPAIGN.
IT’S MORE THAN RAW LUCK.
I DON’T AGREE WITH IT, BUT IF
YOU’RE TRYING TO TAKE MY MONEY,
HOW DID BLOOMBERG GET IT?
THAT’S WHAT I FELT LIKE.
HOW IS HE SO RICH?
WHAT A MORON.
>> Tucker: SO GOOD.